[Music]
you got sure today sure you have your
uterus yeah you have here at Cosi close
yeah what do they know black should
thank you might wanna you know mom and
dad my black boyfriend will be coming up
this weekend I just don't want you to be
shocked but he's a black man if I never
see you like this before brother family
take a road look go back all bougie bear
come back get your damn pants up to your
damn stomach so you guys coming up from
the city yeah I'm just heading up for
the weekend can I see your license
please
he wasn't driving I didn't ask who was
driving I asked to see his ID
call me Dean and go hungry my man so how
long has this been going on this thing
we hired Georgina and Walter to help
care for my parents when they died I
couldn't bear to let him go do you smoke
in front of my daughter
I'm gonna quit she could take care of
that for you how hypnosis I'm good
actually
finis come back and be so look I go
doing my research apparently the whole
bunch of brothers been missing in this
suburb but school we're hot you're not
scared of this man good scene over
brother run here Chris was just telling
me how he felt much more comfortable
with my being here yeah sorry man roast
keys
[Music]
sink into the floor
see
[Music]
[Applause]
just tell me why people are getting
nervous
[Music]
anyway trying to make me believe in
reincarnation are you cuz you're pretty
bet you mean her she got killed
still no arrests how come I wonder cuz
there ain't no God in the whole world's
empty and you don't matter what we do to
each other I hope not
I don't know what the police are doing
I hadn't heard a word from them and some
goddamn behind us I'll tell you this
I've heard an awful lot for them since I
put them billboards up
or a cute case in the public eye
the better your chance second assault
and take them down arrest me they've got
nothing to rest you for oh yeah you
ain't if I had some food I'd give it to
you all I got is some Doritos they might
kill you they're kind of pointy then
where would we be
what has happened is a colossal military
disaster
[Music]
she'll go on to the end we shall never
surrender the call went out we have to
go to Dunkirk ready on the stern line we
do it know where we're going into the
war gorge
I'll be useful sir you start me
it's about three
they need to send more hips every unit
is closer
we've activated the civilian boots
syphilis when they destroy it
we're going Dunkirk
I'm not going back we go they will die
your weekend Salus not a bloody Navy
there's no hiding from this Sun we have
a job to do
we shall fight on the beaches
to fight on the landing grounds
waste of bloody Airport
if I told you about her
the princess without voice what would I
say
[Music]
[Music]
she deaf mute she can hear you you clean
that lab to get out this may very well
be the most sensitive asset ever to be
housed in this facility
you may think that thing looks humans
stands on two legs right but we're
created in the Lord Jim you don't think
that's what the Lord looks like it
this creature is intelligent capable of
language of understanding emotions
[Music]
when he looks at me he doesn't know how
I am incomplete he sees me as I the
natives in the Amazon wears it doesn't
Oh God
get him out you need to take it apart
learn how it works
I don't want an intricate beautiful
thing destroyed we could do nothing I'm
sorry
don't do this Eliza what is she sorry
don't do this that's not even human
if I told you about her what would I say
I wonder
[Music]
I hate California I want to go to the
East Coast I want to go where culture is
like New York I research or at least
Connecticut or New Hampshire writers
live in the wind of those schools anyway
mom she'd just go to City College you
know with your work ethic just go to
City College and then to jail and then
back to City College and then maybe
you'd learn to pull yourself off and not
expect everybody knew everything
Lady Bird is that your given name yeah
why is it in quotes I gave it to myself
it's given to me by me
Lady Bird always says that she doesn't
know wrong side of the tracks but I
always thought that that was like a
metaphor but there are actual train
tracks what she did was very baller very
inner kiss she has a big heart ear mom
she's warm but she's also kind of scary
you can't be scary and warm I think you
can your mom is so you're not interested
in any Catholic colleges no way
I want schools like Yale but not Yale
because I probably couldn't get in
[Music]
you definitely couldn't get in just mom
hate me you're tired we can sit down I'm
not tying or dragging your feet you are
so infuriated off yell I'm not yelling
Oh perfect
love it you both have such strong
personalities
[Music]
when is a normal time do you have sex
you're having sex just wanted it to be
special
why you're gonna have so much on special
sex in your life we're afraid that we
will never escape our past whatever we
give you it's never enough it's never
enough we're afraid of what the future
will bring we're afraid we won't be
loved we won't be like yeah well you
know your mom tips that are totally and
we won't succeed I want you to be the
very best version of yourself that you
can be
what if this is the best version
[Music]
what I'd really like is to be on Math
Olympiad but math isn't something you're
Daria's strong in that we know of yet
[Music]
mr. Perlmutter thank you so much so that
I can show you around
that'd be great thank you
[Music]
so what are you doing around here
read books transcribed music swim at the
river go out at night sounds fun
alright later so they went they made it
to quitter that underscore self just
watch this is how I say goodbye to us
and the time comes later meanwhile we'll
have to put up with him for six long
weeks muscles are firm not a straight
body in these statues they're all curved
sometimes impossibly curved and so no
chalant hence they're ageless and big
you'e t as if they're daring you to
desire them oh you'll see without my
eyes is there anything you don't know
Wow by the time I agree I only knew how
do I know about the things that matter
what things that matter no you know what
thanks I'm saying what I think you're
saying
shouldn't said anything just pretend you
never did
[Music]
[Music]
call me by your name and I'll call you
back
[Music]
so can I ask you a hypothetical question
oh dear I don't like hypothetical
questions no I don't think you're gonna
like the real one either do you have the
papers yet this is a devastating
security breach that was leaked out of
the Pentagon the most highly classified
documents of the war the time says 7,000
pages detailing how the White House has
been lying about the Vietnam War for 30
years the way they lied those days have
to be over okay people are concerned
about having a woman in charge of the
paper but she doesn't have the resolve
to make the tough choices Thank You
Arthur for your frankness let's do our
jobs find those pages you're talking
about exposing years of government
secrets is that legal
what is it you think we do here for a
living kid then I might have something
it must be precious cargo
it's just government secrets the New
York Times was barred publishing any
more classified documents dealing with
the Vietnam War and you'd publish will
be at the Supreme Court next week we
could all go to prison to make this
decision to risk her fortune and the
company that's been her entire life well
I think that's brave if the government
wins Washington Post will cease to exist
and if we don't hold them accountable
who will can't hold them accountable
they don't have a nearest paper Nixon
will muster the full power of the
presidency and if there's a way to
destroy you by God he'll find it I'm
asking your advice not your permission
she can't do this the legacy of the
company is at stake
what will happen if we don't publish
we will lose the country will lose
what are you going to do mrs. Graham you
can sew almost anything into the canvas
and coat when I was a boy they started
to hide things and the linings of the
garments things that only I knew were
there secrets good morning when you have
dinner with me yes I feel as if I've
been looking for you for a very long
time
[Music]
you look beautiful very beautiful I have
things I want to do things I simply
cannot do without you
Reynolds has made my dreams come true
and I have given him what he decides
most to return every piece of me
why are you not married her arrival has
cast a very long shadow she's fairly
looked at here this evening had she may
I warn you of something my brother can
feel cursed that love is doomed for him
and I like this happened maybe one day
you'll change our taste maybe I like my
own taste just enough to get you into
trouble cliffs I'm looking for trends
dog there is a matter of quiet death in
this house you're not cursed you're
loved by me stop playing this game what
game what precisely is the nature of my
game how do you lose in your clothes in
all this money and everything is against
was an ambush doc are you sent here to
ruin my evening he's possibly my entire
life stop it whatever you do do it
carefully
[Music]
we are in the preliminary stage are one
of the greatest battles in history mr.
Winston Churchill you have an enormous
task ahead of you Winston
next judgment is a bully we may have to
replace him no law forces on in Dunkirk
the Germans are pushing us into the sea
you have a full weight of the world on
your shoulders are you not afraid
let's hit it I've screeching for the
first time as Prime Minister Minnesota
an hour for the life of our country you
ask what is our policy I said this to
wage war by sea land and air with all
our might
[Music]